premio emmy a la mejor serie es para
sexta ser por segunda vez la serie de hb
o cuenta la historia de la rica familia
roig cuyos miembros luchan y se
traicionan por el poder al recibir su
corona el creador de la serie james
amstrong lanzó una pulla contra el rey
carlos tercero
después gracias maná para la sucesión es
un nuevo rey del reino unido esto para
nosotros evidentemente ha habido más
votación en nuestro premio que en lo del
príncipe carlos
por otro lado la historia sobre fútbol
americano de appletv blast de plazo se
llevó el premio a mejor comedia también
por segunda vez y entre los grandes
ganadores de la noche un recién llegado
lee yong jae hizo historia al
convertirse en el primer asiático en
ganar el emmy al mejor actor por su
papel en el juego del calamar un éxito
surcoreano que usa un concurso a muerte
como metáfora de la competitividad
desatada por el sistema económico
de
forma que gracias a juan don't you por
mostrar los problemas reales que todos
enfrentamos de forma tan creativa y con
un guión y una imagen tan buenos ser
lille y ralph también hizo historia como
la primera afroestadounidense en ganar
mejor actriz de reparto de comedia por
su rol en abbott elementary un falso
documental ambientado en una escuela
primaria de eeuu una edición número 74
de los premios de la televisión marcada
de nuevo por la competencia entre
plataformas de streaming netflix perdió
suscriptores en los últimos años
superado ya por disney y en términos de
reconocimiento de la industria por hb o
que este año levantó 38 premios emmy